was Winston Churchill really a
progressive Sinclair McKay says so in
this week's magazine he says that
history trying to cast him as a sexist
or imperialist is wide Off the Mark he
joins me to make his case Sinclair is
the 150th anniversary of church Hill's
birth and we live in a world where many
academics and journalists say that he
was racist imperialist sexist your
argument in the swets magazine is that
he was a progressive Pioneer tell us why
he was a progressive Pioneer uh because
uh in in certain flashes of his long
life he lived for 90 years so he was
born in 1874 and lived right the way
through to 1965 the the the apotheosis
of The Rolling Stones uh a great deals
have changed throughout that time and a
great deal changed with church all too
yes he there were many academics who
were interested in appropriating him as
a model of the racist imperialist
genocidal warmonger um but actually
there's all sorts of different other
sides to Churchill that you see peeking
through true uh like flashes from a
diamond all the way could through his
life you mentioned Churchill's views on
gender and sexuality apparently he said
that in the next life he'd like to come
back as a woman and yes he was talking
to his cousin CLA Sheridan in 1920 this
was just two years after the end of the
the first World War uh he was very drunk
he was with several friends of his and
Clare Sheridan in a sort of artistic
retreat in Teddington and she came back
one night to discover Churchill and a
very s non-binary silk dressing gown uh
with several of his friends uh the
absolutely pie eyed on champagne and he
said in the next life I intend to come
back as a woman um you also mentioned in
your you also mentioned in your article
that he had a relationship with Jenny
Lee the labor MP and founder of the open
University who he got on well with what
do you take or what do you read from
that relationship well there are two
different things actually one of the
interesting things about Churchill's
life is this was he he lived at a time
when men generally didn't think that
women should be in politics to begin
with uh and in fact it took him a long
time to come around to to to the suff
Jette movement and votes for women but
also on top of that it was a time when
men found men of his class particularly
found it quite difficult to talk to
women to look women directly in the eye
to treat them as equals Churchill
actually had a number of very strong
friendships uh with a number of actually
rather brilliant uh brilliant women uh
Violet as with Jenny Lee being another
uh because another aspect of his life
was that even though he loathed
socialism in his bones uh detested
communism uh he got on terfly well with
political opponents Jenny Lee was one of
them she was a Firebrand uh labor MP who
got elected to the house in 1929 she was
very young she was in her 20s so an
extraordinary kind of radical figure to
to land in the House of Commons uh all
the way from all the way up to Scotland
you would have thought just the mortal
enemy of Churchill so Churchill just
made of beine for her and she was rather
kind of beguiled by the fact that he was
willing to engage with her and have kind
of the proper kind of debates and so he
would have been regarded by her as a
kind of monster but as their as their
friendship went on through to the 1950s
when she was married to
um uh oh to the man who invented NY
Bavon the man who invented the Health
Service uh even by the 1950s uh she was
she was rather Charmed and beguiled by
by Churchill you also mentioned in your
piece that he may have been slightly
more open-minded on homosexuality than
his peers would have been at the time
absolutely I think in in that sense
church was a curious genuine kind of uh
p
uh one of his best friends Eddie Marsh
who was a brilliant uh not only just a
civil servant but a fantastic of art art
collector artistic figure um Eddie Marsh
was was not exactly openly gay but at
the same time didn't exactly disguise it
either um and he was one of Churchill's
best friends closest Associates for many
many years uh Eddie Marsh introduced him
to the gay composer Ivan noell uh with
whom Churchill also got on toy well he
was very great friends with W Somerset
mm uh the the the gay novelist and again
this was a time where homosexuality was
legal uh so none of these figures would
have proclaimed kind of out loud uh
their their orientation but at the same
time it would have been fairly apparent
to to Churchill who had seen a bit of
the world and understood a bit of the
world uh what they and it made no
difference to him others may have shied
away from such friendships for fear of
Scandal for instance but Churchill never
did you do accept in your piece that
Churchill had quote Grim views on race
what was his Outlook I always slightly
wonder about I mean yes I mean yes he
was racist and people at the time
thought he was racist too it's not it's
not controversial uh to say that but
there are there's different levels to
this uh he was quoted by the as being
incredibly rude about the Indian people
for instance and his own friend Leo amyy
who went to school with him at Harrow uh
was horrified by by Churchill's views on
on India but at the same time there
again there are layers here we think of
church Churchill as a child of Empire he
was he was brought up in it of the
golden sunsets of Empire uh he lived its
kind of fullest life so it would be it
would that to him was the way the world
worked would have been very unusual had
it been had it been otherwise but at the
same time there are other instances in
that uh I was thinking of the 1919
amirit arm Massacre when General Dyer
opened fire on on an unarmed crowd um
and it was expected of Churchill in 1919
that he would stand up in Parliament and
defend General Dy um and his actions and
he didn't he said that this was this was
frightfulness this is exactly the kind
of thing the Empire shouldn't be doing
Empire should not be founded on Force
because if it's founded on force uh then
the entire point of it can of fails so
it's he's in many instances you find
actually he's the the opposite of a
genocidal warmonger he's he's much more
human uh than that there is a real
living human underneath the layers of
caricature of the Church of course
compared to today's standards being
friends with people or not being as
explicitly racist as one might expect in
a moment is a very very low bar I I I I
suppose my question to you is many
people will not accept that Churchill
was pioneering progressivism but they
will still recognize him as an important
historical figure uh do you think that's
fair do you think that's right yes I but
what you also see with Churchill is many
of those who now uh seek to would write
entire books about how he was a
genocidal warmonger imperialist and all
vate in a sense trying to to get control
of History which which is what Churchill
himself was trying to do having written
so much himself over the years uh his
own five volume uh account of uh the
second world war for instance but beyond
that he was always very very piercingly
aware of his own uh part as a landmark
of kind of History even at the time but
it's also important to say it's it's
it's now said that there's a kind of
cult of Churchill that uh that there is
kind of un unreasoning kind of worship
of Churchill and actually that was never
the case case any at any kind of Point
through his life there were always those
who could bitterly absolutely opposed
him and hated him he was hated by so
many Welsh people and still is uh for
his actions at Tony Pandy in in 1910 uh
the general strike of 1926 the entire
labor movement abominated Churchill he
was he was seen as a monster to so many
of them but on the other side of that
when many of his opponents came finally
into close contact with them uh they
they did see that there were kind of
layers layers of confus humor and layers
of compassion too there was the story of
the the Liverpool MP Bessie bradoock who
was a formidable brilliant left-wing
figure in the
1950s uh uh she was implacably opposed
to Churchill there was the famous story
uh where she rounded on Churchill and
said Winston you're drunk and he said
Madam you're ugly but tomorrow I shall
be sober very ungallant I'm not entirely
sure if it actually is true she didn't
even mentioned it in her memoirs but
what she did say in her memoirs was that
uh they they had various other
encounters in the House of Commons and
she couldn't help thinking that actually
all right yes he is the greatest living
Englishman he was a monster for 1926 in
the general strike but there are other
sides of him what sort of conservative
would church will be today where would
he fall in the party oh that's yes
that's a very good question um
especially when it comes to social
issues or small L liberal values yes I
mean would he be it's very difficult to
say would he now fall more on the the
Rory Stewart side rather than the reform
Richard tside I I think he' be and he he
wouldn't be a supporter of Nigel farage
I don't think that
the that that kind of simplistic
populism that bombastic populism uh
would not be a start at all and as I say
there the layers of subtlety in
Churchill's
politics uh he was always open to new he
was in many you know he reformed prisons
for instance which is why I mentioned uh
the the Rory Stewart uh possible uh Ty
he was also he
introduced a certain of Trade union
reforms early in the of the 20th century
which meant that unions could not be
sued by employers automatically so every
time you think of church as being an
extreme right rer you always find a case
of him actually not being an extreme
right-winger all him understanding that
sometimes the economy has to be fixed so
that working people who find themselves
in distress through no fault of their
own have to be helped um in that sense
yes I would
say the the more mod Road potentially on
the left of the party very interesting s
Clair or the part is at stands at the
moment anyway thanks so much for joining
[Music]
me